>>Teacher: What's this
simple machine right here?
Wheel and axle, right.
>>Narrator: Just outside Boston in
the diverse community of Malden,
fifth graders are studying some
of America's oldest technology,
using some of its newest.
>>Teacher: All right,
watch that gate.
>>Narrator: They're on a
field trip to the birthplace
of the country's manufacturing
industry, the Saugus Iron Works.
>>Teacher: This works like a lever.
It presses the bellows closed, it
blows the air into the furnace.
>>Narrator: Public education in
America also began in Massachusetts.
In the mid-1800s, a Prussian system
was adopted that featured reading,
writing and arithmetic taught
in separate periods
governed by the clock.
>>David: We don't live in an
industrial economy any more.
We live in a knowledge economy, and
so we have to think about education
in a fundamentally different way.
We can't be focusing on
basic facts and basic skills.
We have to think about ways
of thinking that are going
to matter more than what we do
in traditional schools right now.
>>Teacher: You want to
be a photo journalist?
>>Students: Yeah!
>>Teacher: Oh, oh, all right!
>>Narrator: Today, many
educators are calling
for an integrated approach
to teaching.
>>Teacher: The circumference
of the circle...
>>Narrator: At Ferryway
School, the Iron Works project,
which is a collaborative effort of a
dozen teachers integrates math, art,
English, history and science.
>>Teacher: Look where
the water's falling.
>>Narrator: And features a
handmade water wheel competition.
>>Students: [clapping]
Go, go, go, go.
>>Earl: The project's not
just about the water wheel,
it's not just about the Saugus
Iron Works, it's about all
of the subject areas
being brought together.
The rocks and minerals.
The simple machines.
The technology concepts and they
learn leadership, they learn how
to get along, how to cooperate.
There's a lot of life
lessons to be learned.
>>Student: And it looks
like shiny metal.
>>Anxhela: If you're like
in different classes,
you sometimes forget, because
your mind's on one class,
and then you have to be
focused on another class.
But when it's all together, you
can just focus on one thing,
'cause it's all the same.
>>Ken: These divisions between
disciplines are provisional at best,
and also in schools, they
become artificially enforced.
>>Narrator: Sir Ken Robinson is an
internationally acclaimed author
and lecturer, and an
expert in creativity.
>>Ken: There's a kind of
assumption that there's a set number
of subjects in the world.
And some of those are more
important than the other ones.
So typically, you end up
with this hierarchy of math
and languages and science at the top.
And they are very important.
But they're not more
important in my view
than the arts and the humanities.
So that's the first thing,
you've got the hierarchy.
The second thing is,
these things tend
to be hermetically sealed
off from each other.
You know, so you do science
on a Thursday morning.
You do math in the afternoons.
And this is really a feature
of education, because outside
of education, people know
naturally that all these things flow
in and out of each other.
You know, that disciplines
affect each other.
>>Karen: So you want to
put your GPSs up this way.
>>Narrator: Across the country,
imaginative teachers make
learning richer and deeper
by connecting subjects
through projects.
>>Karen: We want you to
write down that latitude
and longitude on your paper.
>>Narrator: In the Eastern
Washington town of Waterville,
local farmers team up
with fourth graders
to track tiny horny-toad
lizards as part
of a national program
called Nature Mapping.
>>Karen: And we don't know
what the horny-toads do.
We don't understand what
they do during the winter.
>>Narrator: Teachers and experts
designed an interdisciplinary
curriculum for the year-long project.
>>Karen: And when I saw what
the kids were supposed to do
at different age levels,
I said, "Oh, we have math.
We have science.
We have technology, we have art.
We have all these components."
>>Student: How to catch a horny-toad.
The first thing you have
to have is a good eye.
>>Narrator: At Landry Middle
School, just outside New Orleans,
the eighth-grade teaching team built
an interdisciplinary unit around one
of their students'
favorite subjects, cars.
>>Teacher: Oh, it curves!
Look at that!
>>Narrator: In science class,
students made balloon-propelled cars
out of recycled materials, and
road tested their various designs.
>>Teacher: Try to write some
different selling points.
>>Narrator: In English,
students wrote car commercials.
And in math, they calculated
loan payments.
>>Teacher: Now six percent
of whatever you get
for item number seven.
>>Student: So multiply six percent...
>>Teacher: ...times that.
>>Student: Okay.
>>Linda: I've had kids come
back to me and tell me,
"Do you remember that
project we did?"
They have never, ever
come back and said,
"You remember that test we did?"
So I think that's the impact.
If the kids remember it, our scores
will go up, and our test scores have.
>>Student: Good afternoon.
Welcome to the culminating
event of "Fading Footprints."
>>Narrator: In some schools, like
King Middle School in Portland,
Maine, interdisciplinary learning
drives the entire curriculum,
drawing on knowledge gained
in several different classes,
seventh graders here
produced a CD-ROM
that features Maine's
endangered species.
>>Teacher: The model that we
use is expeditionary learning,
outward bound.
So it's really, it focuses
on hands-on learning.
We try to integrate science,
social studies, math and English
with technology, with artwork,
with community members,
field work, etcetera.
>>Narrator: In the process of
making the CDs, students learn
to collaborate and contribute
their various talents.
In music class, they recorded
soundtracks for the CD;
in art they painted
scientifically accurate watercolors
of their animals.
>>Student: Everybody talks
about field work, and...
>>Narrator: And in video production
class, they made the movie
about the making of the CD.
>>Student: On our winter walk,
we learned about how animals
and plants survive in
Maine's harsh climate.
>>Narrator: Since implementing
the interdisciplinary curriculum,
King principal, Mike McCarthy
has seen the test scores
of King's diverse student body
go from the bottom one-third,
to the top one-third in the state.
>>Michael: I've heard people
describe what a gifted
and talented classroom
would look like.
It should include field experiences,
it should include technology;
it should independent work; it
should include work that's in-depth.
Well, that's basically
what our school is.
One of the kids said, "Nobody
feels stupid around here anymore."
And I think that was one of
our highest achievements.
>>Teacher: Open up,
find "Wild Ginger."
It's on page 59.
>>Narrator: At the School
of Environmental Studies
just outside Minneapolis,
nature provides the context for the
school's interdisciplinary approach
to learning in service
to the community.
>>Dan: We work with
the local communities.
We have 20 ponds and lakes
that we are monitoring every
year since we've been open.
And so the kids go out and do a
chemical analysis of the water.
They also will write
a technical paper.
And then they present their findings
to the water commissioners
from the local cities.
And those people actually
will be the student work.
>>Student: Could use
one more, I think.
>>Student: We need one more.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Mark: When you go to a normal
high school you get biology
and earth science and English,
and then here you get just world,
you get everything,
and it's all together.
And you realize that it's all
systemic, and it all connects.
And you leave here, you
know, with real value.
>>Teacher: So that would be one
of the predators of the pond.
>>Amanda: I can't learn
from a textbook.
I can't concentrate.
I don't have the ability
to concentrate like that.
And here, with the hands-on
activities that we do,
and the integration of
everything into our daily lives,
it helps me absorb the
information a lot better.
>>Student: All right,
recreational use.
>>Narrator: Instead of
tests in various subjects,
the school judges presentations
to peers and content experts
as a better way to assess the
understanding of complex subjects.
>>Teacher: And through biological
magnification the tiger hare is then
poisoned because it eats the fish.
>>Tom: I think that
where we are is a lot
like when the Wright Brothers
flew the first airplane.
Imagine for a minute when the Wright
Brothers flew their first airplane,
everybody running up to
them, congratulating,
saying, "That's wonderful."
And someone walks up and says,
"Well, that's impressive,
but how is it going to
improve the railroad?"
The standards for performance
that we're using are
railroad performances.
>>Teacher: Today you are
going to take the SAT-1.
>>Tom: So we're kind of
locked in by those standards
to fixing the railroad, when we need
to get busy on inventing flight.
>>Narrator: In industries
like filmmaking and gaming
where collaboration and
creativity are prized,
employers are looking
for people who can fly.
>>Randy: Education has been
a lot about accruing facts.
And today, getting facts is a
lot easier than it's ever been.
But doing something interesting
with those facts, it's not so much
in the points themselves, but in
the relationship between them.
>>Teacher: And you don't
have to scrap the design,
'cause the design is beautiful.
>>Randy: One of the things that comes
out of that interdisciplinary kind
of learning is it forces
people to examine patterns.
And the real knowledge is when you
recognize the complexity of a pattern
and then can resolve it into
a simplicity that allows it
to be applied to something else.
That's so much of the business of
art and technology and breakthrough.
>>Narrator: Further
breakthroughs in education will come
from understanding that people
learn best by integrating bits
of information, and combining them
to create something that is greater
than the sum of its parts.
>>Student: There's actually
230 endangered species.
>>Ken: For a really innovative
creative education, you simply have
to have a broad curriculum.
One that includes the arts,
as well as the sciences,
as well the humanities and
languages and technology.
>>Teacher: We're going
to take the math idea
of below zero and turn it into music.
>>Ken: For there's
no doubt in my mind
that a really creative
school encourages all kinds
of interaction between subjects.
There's just no doubt about that.
>>Teacher: Oh, I see some really
wonderful positive negatives,
just like those math numbers.
Great!
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.